so I didn't know this until we did a
story on it last week but apparently
there is porn on the computer machine
and a new study in the archives of
sexual behavior is basically proving
that if you watch too much porn
especially for men it actually affects
your sexual behaviors let's take a look
at a little info from the study
researchers studied 487 male college
students they found that how often men
watched porn correlated directly with
how much they wanted to act out scenes
they'd seen the more they watched the
more they relied on pornographic
fantasies in the bedroom as well now
again because I did not know that there
was porn online until last week I did a
little research cuz we're a thorough
show here so I went to pornhub calm and
this is the front page of pornhub.com I
didn't type anything in this is the
front page pornhub.com so these as you
can see in the upper left there these
are the porn videos being watched
either videos being watched right now
and I think this sort of illustrates the
point of the of the study I'll let you
guys handle a couple of these but
doesn't this got horny anal
which one do you want to field one
Comfort cuties yeah that's pretty mild
then do you want to pick a favorite
there well for I like I liked this is
and this is a surprise and I hope I'm
not out of school here but I like corny
anal to better than the
better than the original yeah because
there was more horny and and in
the first one it was really it was just
a which is fine yeah but I thought
they just disregarded it but there were
so there's a little more of a story
right all right just go back to that for
just a second I thought the other
interesting one was Muslim double
all the time yeah Jen comes over
and we
Mia Khalifa brings her big tips
sometimes she leaves them there where
does she live at home but this time she
decided to bring them along right now
okay so obviously they're pure mature
sexy wife Lisa and thanks hubby that's
not a poor title because he stopped at
the Outback Steakhouse on the way home
and brought dinner home she didn't have
to cook it like oh honey thanks I'm
gonna guess that as a married man you've
never been thanked in the way that that
woman probably thanked her anyway look
obviously we could do a zillion stories
and just laugh about the title do you
think but I do think it does illustrate
the point that they're saying that this
stuff is so accessible obviously to all
of us and we've all watched it blah blah
blah but do you think it actually does
with people's expectations of sex
this study was really about men but even
for women I mean it really depends on
where you got your sex education from
right so if you grew up on porn and you
didn't have access to comprehensive sex
education you're more likely to think
hey this is what sex is really supposed
to be like which is why I'm such a huge
advocate for a comprehensive sex ed it
not only teaches kids what's right and
wrong it also teaches kids how to
protect themselves and all of that but
also you know I would make the argument
that a lot of adults know that what they
see in pornography is a fantasy right
there's some porn out there that's you
know in a gray area for me you know
there's like rape porn incest porn all
of these like really really shady
categories and there have been studies
that prove that just because people
watch that type of pornography and they
fantasize about it doesn't mean that
they want to carry it over into their
actual sex lives right so again it
really depends on an age group it really
depends on how influential these people
are or I'm sorry how easily influenced
these people are it really depends so
that goes to the point that people
always say with video games violent
video games make you violent except
every study shows that that's actually
not the truth and I would get venture to
say that if you're watching some weird
porn it doesn't automatically mean that
you know you want to pee on someone or
whatever it is then take away what what
what are you doing over there Ben he's
actually doing research while we're just
collar yourself as a family show do you
think it changes do you think it changes
your expectations substantive believe
that study yeah I think it I think
certainly it does and I'm not sure that
that that all by itself is horrible yeah
you know if it makes people more
adventurous and tries things and frees
people to do stuff that they would have
thought was crazy great if it puts
pressure on people or sets an
unreasonable expectation then it's bad
but there's a lot of ground in the
middle there so I don't think it's bad
yeah do you guys think the final one
should you know too much if you lose
sense of reality then obviously it's
crossed into it says the guy watching
porn while sitting here doing so she's
very she seems she seems that's horny
anal for like we all talk
look porn it's become normalized which I
actually think is good so people don't
have to it's not this shameful whatever
I think that's great
but anything there's something to be
said for not having full access to it
then what you know do you mean like I'm
sure when you were a kid you probably
had to find your dad's stack of Playboy
magazines right I don't think had a
brother 12 years older that was the
greatest yeah yeah cuz he could go by
employers well he just I just found his
stack and right yeah so but do you think
that we so the kids sort of like they're
just being hit with this immediately
like they can just go on like like that
I guess that's the point your point
about education yeah I mean look I was
hit with it immediately and I know that
I'm not really the demographic that
we're talking about right now but yeah I
had access to porn at a really young age
but again I also had access to really
good sex education look the only thing
you can do to combat the bad influences
is make sure that people are educated
and unfortunately we've moved away from
that notion and we have like these
alarmist views when it comes to things
like pornography and I love the point
that been made if porn is what yeah I do
well not the one about you like losing
it over the computer screen right now
but just the argument that look if
pornography is making you a little more
curious and adventurous in the bedroom
there's really nothing wrong with that
and it's important to have a
conversation with the person you're
having sex with to make sure that he or
she is comfortable with the things you
want to try out there you go beg your
the final thought yeah you know you
mentioned when when that the upsetting
parts of porn the you know the incest or
the and I was given a box of every guy
has this story some kind older gentleman
some friend who's been caught or
whatever has to give up his giant box of
porn and I got a giant box
or fairly late in life like when I was
living in Miami yeah and included in
this box was you put it in and it was a
it was incest it was I mean they're
actors but it was a father having sex
with his grown daughter and the mother
being upset so retaliating by having sex
with the son battle shop yeah
and it was incredibly disturbing it was
so disturbing that I had to mute it you
see there you see what he did
[Music]